Patrick with David and today I want to
share with you a couple videos I saw
that's complete opposite of each other
regarding teachers one is an example of
a student who in the middle of a class
his name is Jeff bliss gets upset at his
teacher and stands up and says this to
her on this video which went viral
here's the video there's kids they need
face-to-face just getting mad because
I'm pointing out the obvious you choose
you know not wasting your time I'm
telling you what you need to do you want
kids to come into your class you want to
get excited you got to come in here you
got to make them excited you want a kid
to change and start doing better you got
to touch his freaking heart can't expect
a kid to change the ball you do is just
tell me you got it you got an image job
series this is the future of this nation
and when you come in here like you did
last time and make a statement about oh
this is my paycheck indeed it is but
this is my country's future in my
education but there's the limit when I'm
not bitching but simply making an
observation okay and now I will leave
you're welcome
and if you would like I'll teach you a
little more so you can actually learn
how to teach a freaking class because
since I got here I've done nothing but
read packets so don't try and take
credibility for teaching me yeah
he saw the video and some may say he was
out of place he did the right thing they
investigated the teacher the teacher
wasn't really teaching that
investigations been taking place with
the teacher she was asked not to work
and you hear a story like that and you
wonder my kids go to school
that's taxpayer money you and I pay for
that should teachers be held at a higher
standard just like employees are if I do
a wrong thing and I'm working for
company I could get fired but sometimes
with teachers you can't because of the
tenure so should that happen and how do
you go about holding them accountable
but on the other side here's a video of
a teacher that completely inspired many
students for his students to say these
things about him I don't fall asleep in
his class I just don't it's weird
because I can remember falling asleep in
every other class I've never had a
teacher like in at all my calculus every
day just I pass out hey he's probably
one of the teachers like probably when
I'm 75 years old that also remember ours
he's I fall asleep in there all the time
the he's the epitome of what I think is
easier should be mr. a has a key to the
city yeah I just tend to fall asleep a
lot it's a bad thing but I do but this
class just keeps me interested so
there's no room for napping because
you're learning
this guy's just crazy
he's just exploding with fun you see a
huge fireball burning my hand and go up
to the ceiling and I don't matter I'm
not gonna have any kids sleeping and
every one of those people are out there
asking how how how how and as soon as
you get the kid asking how or why I
could rope him in and get that intrigue
going what's good is a love of Marty he
says I could care less about Newton's
third law I want to teach something for
you to take outside of school that's
what he's told us before so he really it
makes me feel like he really cares about
me and I know he does he's a good man
and he will still go out of his way
pretty powerful huh to have a teacher
like that where the kid says he's got
the key to the city can you imagine the
kind of influence that teachers may
where the girl says I want to remember
him in my 70s and I think we all have a
teacher like that we remember you see
what all these conversations taking
place with common core and everybody
talking about what's gonna happen to our
educational system are we going in the
right direction are we getting soft
there are we getting away from math are
we going too much towards creativity and
not enough towards math and history and
the things that really matter and what
are we really gonna do with this is this
really gonna be effective I think it's
something that everybody needs to
constantly be thinking about and talking
about because if there's one thing
that's a very very important that is our
educational system and for every bad
teacher that does what the lady did and
there's many teachers like her out there
by the way she's not the only one there
are many many teachers but for everyone
like her there are many many many others
multiples who go to work every single
day wanting to make a pie
sort of impact in your kids lives there
are so many of them who genuinely go to
work they don't get paid a lot of money
to make 40 50 60 70 some eighty thousand
dollars per year but they want to give
back to their country and do something
about it and so if you got a teacher
like that who is like the last one we
just saw everyday heroes that we don't
hear about all the time share this video
with them tell them how awesome they are
tell us about the story of your teacher
whoever it is we want to know about
those stories because I think sometimes
we see a lot of people on news and we
see a lot of the celebrities on news the
rock stars all these other people we
forget who are everyday heroes are so
this message today was purely dedicated
to teachers one to hold them accountable
to the other side do once you actually
go to work doing it the right way thank
you so much for your time and dedication
into the future of America it's my
message of the week to you